depuis les accidents la semaine dernière
la ville de montréal revoit actuellement
les règlements qui encadrent la
circulation des camions doit-on par
exemple limiter le passage sur certaines
rues des camions le responsable avait le
doit rencontrer cette semaine
l'association du camionnage du québec
émilie dubreuil est allé dans un camion
pour voir justement le point de vue les
camionneurs ça fait 30 ans que paul
lambert oeuvre derrière un volant jamais
aussi heureux que dans son camion il est
conscient que ce qu'il appelle sa
deuxième maison plutôt s'y constituer
une arme offensive nous avons on pèse 80
mille vies et c'est vous accrocher les
enfants s'ils avaient quelque chose bien
enfin
mais les accidents les dernières
semaines ont permis au moins de mettre
en lumière un véritable problème de
cohabitation routière on en parle déjà
de joie c'est un bon point de vente en
parler parce que les cyclistes c'est un
facteur de stress
puisqu'on parle comme faux je les vois
il n'y a pas de strass à ce moment c'est
quand je les vois pas arriver à ce
moment alors
les camionneurs en général n'aiment pas
bien en ville
vous voyez ça ça me stresse les piétons
les moutons les poussettes
il n'y a pas que les bicyclettes qui
lisent stress le problème c'est que les
vélos empruntent les voies des véhicules
automobiles et que c'est pas adapté à
eux
moi j'avais pensé à des rues peut-être
un peu plus secondaires un peu comme une
autoroute de vélo on peut reprendre la
lutte lors qu'à certains endroits la rue
saint-dominique unis le secondaire enfin
seulement que des vélos du patin à roues
alignées vous voyez ici à contresens est
le parfait mieux encadrer le camionnage
à montréal paul lambert n'est pas contre
mais il voudrait bien que les cyclistes
fassent leur bout de chemin
ici émilie dubreuil radio canada
montréal